oops
action share a different way
let's see well for people who are
joining this live stream we are talking
about the foreign function interface
and
I know nothing so Christopher is going
to explain this
sure
uh well basically this is a packlet that
uses the basically uses the compiler
stuff like like Library function
declaration to connect to a library
called lib ffi which lets you connect to
other libraries
so the sort of the main difference
between well so maybe two two points the
first thing is it's different from
library link because in library link the
library is linked to they have to expose
functions they're in a very particular
format that's specific to connecting to
you know a open language kernel and so
you know you can't just connect to some
random library in the wild you have to
compile something in between which you
have to generally write in C C plus plus
or something like it
um the other uh the other distinctions
this is a bit different from the
compiler the compiler methods for
connecting to libraries because this is
all at runtime so with those you have to
basically compile some some uh some
library that that links between you know
the external library and and the kernel
here there's no intermediate no
compilation has to happen in order to
call a foreign function okay so what's
an example of a thing that exposes is a
foreign function an interface that is
capable of being connected to like this
uh well an obvious example at whole I
don't have a maybe I'll I'll
I think I have a guide page that will
show this
um one one obvious example would be um
uh would be like you know I have some
like open SSL examples or like sqlite
examples okay where you can see uh let
me just understand I mean open SSL
cut is delivered as a library is that
right what what kind of a DOT what kind
of file is it
um
it's it's uh basically it's two dot SOS
or dot UI Libs or or whatever I think
it's different on Windows but but
ultimately it's something like that okay
but do those do those libraries do those
files have a discovery interface of some
kind that lib ffi can hook into or how
does it work not really they don't they
don't really
um
they yeah there isn't really Discovery
interface instead it's just if you you
know you DL open a library based on the
path and then you call DL Sim and it
will you give it the name of a function
and it will give you a function pointer
oh my God so that's essentially what
this is doing okay so this is okay and
then how does but how does it know what
the calling structure of that function
is or it doesn't you have to tell it
that you have to tell it so you have to
tell it this is the type signature of my
function and then this is the magic of
lib ffi is is is knowing given this is
the type and here's a function pointer
how do I actually call this function
I see so hold on so I mean
in these are non-stripped binaries so
they still have the names of the symbols
and numbers that right or am I confused
yeah I mean they still yes they still
have the names these are Dynamic
libraries Dynamic libraries not DOT lib
files
shared libraries you know dynamically
loaded libraries
so clear even even stripped libraries
still have even strip Dynamic libraries
still have the symbol names because
that's fundamental to being able to use
them yeah right right okay right so I
mean and and I see so
just so I understand the technology a
bit because I need to be modernized here
you know in an actual binary an
executable
there is only one entry point
it's just main or whatever
and so for example if you strip the
binary then there are no there are no
readable string next symbol names at all
there is that correct
just binary
or is that not known to you guys I I
don't really know how how that works I
mean I know obviously if you do run
strings or whatever names or whatever on
a stripped binary like the the kernel
you do still see some strings but I
think it's just string literals and
stuff right you don't see but before you
strip the binary the loader still has
actual names of strings that correspond
to this but so what your the point
you're making is a dynamic Library if
you don't have those names you have no
idea you know what the entry point what
the address
to go to to execute anything is
therefore those things are still there
in a dynamic Library
okay right and you see this if you do
you know Library uh whoops Library
function load you know Library function
load takes library and then a function
name right and then the type signature
okay so there's a mechanism for okay so
then okay so what's happening here is
you've got the library
you've got a name of a function
and I mean does it matter what kind of a
you know how this library was created
what language it came from things like
that to the or does how does the what
I'm well so so I mean basically uh all
different languages have different ways
of putting function arguments On The
Stack
it has to have C linkage right you see
linkage right yeah c-a-b-i compatible
yes which which basically all as far as
I know I mean maybe Fortran or Cobalt is
different as far as I know any language
that really claims to be able to produce
a dynamic Library produces a dynamic
library that it conforms to the cabi
on your whole system will use the same
format okay I think you're right the
photon Works differently or at least
used to maybe it's maybe made compatible
but but no one is going to be like
here's a DUI lib from Fortran and
they're not gonna if they do that
they're gonna make it very clear that
they're giving you something very
strange yeah I hope well and I'm sure
this C interface layer has probably been
built for Fortran by now okay I I think
I understand what the theory is here
okay now what happens so
right so so now what happens is so it's
okay here for instance I have a um this
is just a demo library that you know
just comes in the the product and it
includes a function called add one that
takes an interns an INT so what I'm
going to do is I can say create form
function and given that this library's
already been loaded and it's sort of in
the it's it's in the system I can run
this and it'll create this sort of
foreign function object
and I can call it by saying call foreign
function I can give it the object and I
can give it a list of its arguments and
it will give me the output and so why
isn't that you know a thing that's
called foreign function of blah blah
blah with sub-value 12. you mean this
why don't I write this yes
um well a decorator of add one
I mean it could be it could be a blob
in other words you could have a thing
called foreign function
and then it's why isn't it that yeah um
it could be yeah it could be I mean so
the reason that I haven't done that yet
is is sort of for silly performance
reasons that basically when I make it a
sub value so this call to to you know
call foreign function is like very has
very little overhead I think it's like
on the order of like yeah 10 to the
minus seven seconds the overhead of
running a single sub value is 10 to the
minus six seconds
so it's sort of uh you know for the
purposes of minimizing overhead which is
like one of the nice things
you know it sort of destroys it to use a
sub value but but I understand that I
mean ultimately they'll have to be a
version of this that exposes a sub value
because people often don't care about
you know that level of uh of right well
maybe there's a way of optimizing the
sub-value and certainly if you compile
the thing the compiler should
immediately
you know
I mean part of what you're saying there
is there might be a level of quotes
compilation that's just a rewriting a
transformation from the sub-value to
that core foreign function thing that
you know I I I I mean the best thing to
do will be to fix the overhead but the
sub value
maybe but that might be a deeply
ingrained thing in the in the you know
in the kernel it might be but I I think
I would predict okay
but that's a okay right no but that's a
defined survival what if it's a c code
sub value
what if it's a I forgot what it's called
s value or whatever s function yeah I'm
not sure I bet that that would be fast
yeah this isn't also so bad I mean it's
an order of two
slower but that's not it's still and
that's the top level code
right so with with I I think this is
going to be a no problem thing yeah okay
fine and I think it's nice because we've
got external function
what's the relationship the explainable
relationship between foreign function
and external function well I think
that's one thing that I mean if we're
talking about including in the system
that's I think an important topic
because I think arguably this should
just go into external function but maybe
Todd has a different
yeah well I was thinking about that I'm
not
I'm not exactly sure if external
function has this notion of a session uh
you know it's designed for external
evaluate where you have you know a long
lived it would probably work fine to
just have this be an external function
return from create foreign function uh I
haven't there might be some weird
impotence mismatch between I I think
it's not a good idea I think that this
thing
you see I think external function
foreign well I was going to say is
really a creature of interpreted
languages but that's not really right
and also I would have imagined that the
defining the reason why we have external
function not just external evaluate is
so that we can do stuff like connect to
compiled languages yeah well right but I
mean look at that external function
python ABS I mean that's a very weird
thing because it's based on a session
as opposed to
being you know it is it is a function
that comes from an external session of
some kind
I mean would it make sense I mean if we
just defined some kind of special
session that is the current kernel State
you know the the dynamically loadable
it's different but it'd be distinct the
first usage is just sets not session
right so I mean that's what this is
doing I mean this is secretly creating a
python session but I think it's not
inconsistent with the second the first
usage to do something like this
right
the system is C or something like it and
the you know this is the function
right I might suggest just C ABI since I
mean this was talked about lots of
languages support the cabi but the
cabbie yeah
I think we want the name to suggest that
it's like the current you know it's it's
in process whereas that python thing is
obviously a whole different process
um it's the current you know memory
space of the current process
some name that evokes that yeah
right that seems more relevant I mean
that the
external function of dynamic library but
I kind of like the foreign function
brand
I mean plus there's a bunch of other
support functions and maybe they all
start with ffi or something you know we
have to Brand all these things anyways
well let's take a look at some more of
the design but but I I strongly think
that the way this should be called in
the end is it should just look like
you know it could even have a nice
decorated blob
right I totally agree that this really
needs a foreign function object as the
return or a external function some sort
of blob that then you can just call as a
function
but so let's understand how do you how
do you get to this so
you say load a library library load of
something
and then right
now so so that thing of create foreign
function that takes some effort for it
to do that is that correct that's not
just a that's not just a action it's not
just a symbolic rapper
it's not just it I mean it takes it not
very much effort but I mean basically
it's calling DL Sim which is the
function for a given you have a loaded
giving you a loaded Dynamic library or
an open Dynamic Library find me the
function pointer for this symbol and
it's doing a little bit of allocation
but that that's about it
okay oh talking of allocation what
happens when
um
is there a bunch of memory management
footwork that has to be done around this
stuff
um yes not around this but around you
know there are basically a whole bunch
of functions that that are the main kind
of arguably you know is most of the
stuff in this packlet you know which are
which are about producing for you know
producing arguments that you can give to
this thing and then interpreting things
that you get back and those have to do
lots of memory management dancing
okay so hold on so so but the basic
workflow here is
if I see some random Library let's take
GEOS as an example
I mean could you just say library load
of I mean that's a file name that you're
putting in the Library log function
right
yeah well actually just might be if I do
okay I can cheat a little bit because I
know that GS if I do this
and I say you know
or two GEOS of
this might load slightly slowly because
of uh oh no it's fine okay so now I know
GEOS is loaded so if I do you know GEOS
I don't know GEOS intersection and then
I said uh you know this takes two
pointers and returns a pointer you know
there it is that's a callable thing now
I mean it's not one that I can call
right here because making these pointers
requires calling other GEOS functions
and I I don't remember all the names of
them but yeah but that's basically what
you would do
so is it the case that you know given
that you loaded a library can you do
Discovery at the level of even knowing
what the symbols are in that Library
how do we do that there must be a way to
extract information on what the symbols
are in a library
so I I'm I don't really know too much
about it I know there is sort of a
metadata field in Dynamic libraries
where you can put sort of arbitrary
information
um
which which goes and finds you the
function points uh for a function there
must be something that lists all the
things up for which you can do that
right so two things the first thing is I
don't think it knows that I don't think
it knows the types you have to tell the
types DL Sim doesn't know the types okay
the second thing is
I'm yeah I'm not entirely sure how that
works and I'm not sure if you really can
get a list easily
seems like it'd be nice if one could
because that would be a you know to me
what does Library load return
Library load returns a path I think that
it loaded from
okay but the alternative will be to
return a blob that is a symbolic thing
representing a library
perhaps
um
I mean one one problem is that I mean
for example so the way debuggers work is
as I understand it is that if you're
debugging an executable it has debug
information and there's a format dwarf
which is it seems to be kind of a
semi-cross platform standard for this
the debugger reads the data in that
format and that's how it can do things
like for example you know if you say if
you say print out this particular stack
frame and it shows you all the local
variables at that frame in the stack and
it can even format them if it has Type
information you know so if one's a
string and one's an integer or whatever
it can use the dwarf debug information
to know that and format it so I think
there is a world in which it's in
principle possible to derive this from
it from a library but it's only possible
if that library has debug information
which is not obviously generally
consumed and kind of a released okay
sorry yeah yeah right but so I mean your
point is if you compile the library
let's say you were trying to write this
in the most stupid possible way you know
you don't know assume you can't read the
code of the library very well
um
well okay so we have to make some
assumptions if you were able to
recompile the library in debug mode and
read its dwarf file or something then
perhaps you could get some discovery
that way
that may be fictional I mean there's not
be a situation that you're ever in but
you can't read the code
but yet you can recompile
I think it's easier to read the code
than to recompile often and also there's
documentation like if you're really
trying if you're yeah if you're being to
use this sort of thing you need to
it's not that useful to have a discovery
mechanism that simply lists the symbols
from a dynamic library because you can't
call them unless you have
full documentation and so you basically
have to go to the docs or or some
example code or something that uses
these functions in C or some other
language and then
I think you have to go modern you have
to go ask your your favorite chat bot
yeah yeah writer to generate fake
examples
foreign function uh call for this
certain function from a certain library
and spit it back might work
well I mean you know so this is this is
I think
maybe a kind of phase two
there are a couple different phase twos
that could happen but one phase two
would be uh to to basically try and read
header files to automatically call
create form function and that seems like
that that's usually the way that people
try and automatically you know do
Discovery for libraries like this it's
also a method that based on everything
I've I've read is like extremely fraught
and it basically the try doesn't really
work twice at least twice by various
people during rectangular at all from
and it's never been successful to try to
parse hitter files there's always
something what does Chris Cooley's stuff
do does it for a set of files or does it
make
I think it's going the other direction
no it passes C code and oh that's stuck
yeah yeah that that's something else
yeah
it does parse C code
um
so is that is that known to work or not
work for this purpose so I looked at it
a while ago so I looked at that and I
looked at clang link because clang link
uh also has stuff for parsing header
files
um I think
Chris's stuff was a little more it was a
lot cleaner but it cleaned up some of
the information I think he kind of
needed in order to do this
um
I finally had more information but also
had a bunch of other junk but part of
the problem is that they're they're
issues like okay real libraries have
tons of macros in their headers
right so you know they have any flows
so you essentially have to do
compilation
you know with all the macros set and so
on in order to even know what the header
files say before you can post once the
macros are expanded it's a big pile of
mess
which you can't read sure right so I
mean this is like one of 15 problems
okay so fine let's talk about the actual
realistic workflow because you know it
could be that that's having a
labor-saving device that saves you know
five minutes of labor on something that
necessarily takes five hours is
pointless
so I mean right it's much easier just to
go to the you know the documentation for
openssl and see what the signature is
then have it trying yeah but I mean what
is your workflow then so you go to the
documentation you look at the signature
you're going to have to make up what the
corresponding or from language binding
for that function is for example right
we can do an example so I'm gonna this
is what I've done before I think there
may even be an example below for this
but we can we can try and just do it so
that we go through it so this is a
function open SFL Rand bytes that
generates you know you know
cryptographically secure pseudo-random
number generator
right so if we want to call it so here's
here's its its signature so let's let's
do it so I happen to know open SSL is
already loaded by default so we're going
to say create
born function nope Rand bytes normally
you'd call library load before this but
then we have an opaque raw pointer
for the first argument all pointers
arrays whatever are all just opaque
pointers if you want to have more typing
that's a layer above this and it takes
an internet returns an end and
yeah sorry I just asked real quick
because because obviously um you pointed
out that openssl is already loaded by
default so it's not necessary to list it
in that create foreign function call
what what uh
when you ultimately call DL Sim what
value are you passing is the first
argument
um I'm trying to remember it's either
you pass null or you pass there's some
like rtld default I think okay which
basically because so so basically that
first argument is not all right so right
DL Sim takes two arguments takes the
name of the function it takes quote
unquote a handle to the library to sort
of prioritize when loading in but
actually what I think it basically does
it it searches everything in the process
and that handle only really tells it
what to prioritize so if there was a
conflict it will check that one first
so arguably create foreign functions
should have maybe at least an optional
argument that lets you actually I have
internally but it's not documented a a I
think it's called like create foreign
function with library that that uses
that mechanism
um yeah and that was what I was curious
about because like like Library function
load for example you know the the
library link mechanism requires you to
specify the name of the library and that
that kind of makes sense at least
conceptually to me because you can
imagine it's not terribly hard to to
predict that some libraries will have
symbols that have the same name I mean
many libraries will have like an
initialize function now hopefully they
prefix it with something that's kind of
specific to that library but
right I wonder if it shouldn't be the
default that you specify the name of the
library notice this point but it seems
right to me I mean wasn't it Library
name arrow that or or right so two two
things the first thing is that Library
function load does something totally
weird because when you call library load
it doesn't just call DL open it calls DL
open and it puts the handle in some sort
of central registry of all loaded
libraries
um loaded libraries I don't uh I don't
think so
um I think there's like it's like in
some weird internal kernel thing it
keeps track of what libraries you've
loaded and the handles and you keep
shopping with the pads and the handles
associated with them
um right I think probably the better way
to do it you know
sort of as mentioned earlier with
calling Library load is have you know
Library load returns some Library object
that's basically the handle and then
when you call library function load or
whatever else you use that handle again
I I think it'd probably break a lot of
things to change that though
um what would it I understand what would
it break because if you don't specify it
you're saying that many would break
stuff because things assume that Library
load returns a path
well we maybe we didn't need a different
name than Library load right so I have
internally I have a function here I I
don't I don't remember what it's called
but I have a function that's um that's
basically uh uh loads opens a library
and creates this sort of Library handle
um it's basically exactly what we're
saying uh
right oh load external Library there it
is so if I say
um
uh let's see load external library and I
think this might this is not really a
consumerized function yes I need to say
find library here but obviously you
could do that itself and that produces
this external Library handle and then I
can do create form function with Library
beautifully named and I'll give it this
as its first argument like Library
function load and it will use that to
prioritize
okay so yeah so I mean so okay so one
piece of this is the flow of
I mean it seems like the obvious thing
to do would be much like external
evaluate with that session type stuff
there's either you have given a a
pre-digested blob as the specification
of where the library what the library is
or you could perhaps give a string and
it will on demand when you say create
the foreign function it will
you know load the library appropriately
does that make sense right so you'd
either I mean right I mean one version
of that would just be their two usages
of this one that takes two arguments one
that takes three if it was inside of
external function it would be that you
either write quotes Dynamic libraries
its first argument or you first have a
start external session of dynamic
Library comma a path and that creates a
quote unquote session but the session is
just one of these external Library
handles
sounds about right I mean right
I mean this is essentially how how
I think how kind of everything works in
in the external uh yeah evaluate
external value so you do something like
this that creates an external Library
handle and then when you do external uh
function
you can either just as either you can
write python or you can give it a python
session here you can either give it this
object or you can just say Dynamic
Library
yes in which case it'll create that but
how does it know which library to create
if you just say Dynamic library though
oh well it does what this does it just
assumes it's already been linked okay
fine but you can also do a thing I think
but the external the external functions
external evaluate stuff already does we
can say Dynamic Library Arrow blah blah
blah there's some Syntax for that I
forget exactly how it works if you look
up external evaluate I think it has but
that's like that that's the return value
that arrow thing oh okay yeah right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right that's the wrong thing
that's for interpreted languages
defining the return value
but what's the I mean wouldn't that be
in the second argument
if you do
external evaluate
oh yes but this question is where's the
name of the dynamic Library yeah the
point is if you go ahead what's the
advantage of start external session
versus load library library book right I
mean there's some Global State all the
libraries loaded into the kernel and why
not just say library load and then I I
strongly agree that it's useful to have
a syntax in create Form and Function
that takes a library name or Library
specification of some kind and just do
it all in one shot but why why why call
start external session here it's really
just another way to do you might as well
just call library load if you can do it
separately
right well maybe I can look into I mean
the the basic reason I mean for the
purpose of this being in a packlet is
that
uh you need to get that that Library
handle and that's only available when
you call library load like ultimately
when you load the function with DL Sim
you don't need a path you need this
Library handle and the only reason that
that works with Library load you know
the only reason why Library load can get
away with not returning the handle is is
because there's this secret internal
registry mapping paths to handles and I
don't have access to that as a packlet
um right maybe I could be exposed
okay so let's Okay so we got a a bucket
of stuff to do with the specification of
the library
and
the we still believe that it's
worthwhile well I mean foreign function
might be able to have a an absolutely
you know
okay you know
do it on demand as opposed to create
foreign function which does a one-time
Dy Sim or whatever it was called thing
so you mean you'd have like a foreign
you'd have like a whole thing is there
the library specification everything and
it's just and it just literally you you
just call it and in a perfect world that
would cache itself and things like this
yeah that could be interesting
so so you just you just write something
like this instead of saying you know F
Beth equals create foreign function of
blah blah blah and then ff of this you
would instead just write this
we just get rid of create form function
right right it would just be it would
just be this
right right and it evaluates and then
foreign function would evaluate to
something that has a bit more uh you
know material in it yeah that that could
work I mean and the overhead for for
this is low enough that it's I mean as
you saw it's like 10 to the minus six or
something yeah so it's sort of like uh
you know the the cost of calling a
resource function is is probably much
higher right
so Donald live stream is asking why not
have create ffi of typed of the function
name comma the signature
now that's why I have the type be
separate rather than just saying typed
of right well this we have this
discussion of it with Library function
declaration I think the argument is that
when you write typed you want it to
really be the case that the object in
the first argument has this type but
here this object is a string it's not
like at best you'd want to write
something like in the compiler you'd
write something like this
right to say that that this thing has
has this type otherwise it's just sort
of dishonest because you're just saying
this string has this type but it makes
sense
because right because the the foreign
function has not yet made itself a thing
that could have a type the foreign
function is is um yeah this is just a
string
all right so let's assume it's I mean I
kind of prefer the foreign function
brand here to to trying to stuff this
into external function but maybe maybe
that's not right
oh maybe the thing to do is I should I
should make this version of it where
it's just using foreign function and
where it sort of has this this syntax
like this that's probably a bit closer
to
the the Syntax for external evaluating
let's see what it's like fair enough but
then then there's a preamble there
which is very much like start external
session but it is the only you know it
could be even start Dynamic library or
load Dynamic library or something I mean
we we can get out of the problem of the
fact that Library load which is an old
function doesn't do quite the right
thing I think we can have an overlay of
something different because this is
going to be the modern version of this
okay yeah
but let's yeah go ahead uh I mean it may
be the case that if you know if any
occult foreign function directly we can
have it do the new Behavior could
Library load though I noticed it seems
like forever it's had in one argument
form could it have a two argument form
or the second argument is some kind of
uh you know a specification of what it
should return like a handle or a path
like just a string that's the type
returns first thing arrow and then what
it should return or that yeah something
along those lines usually that might be
meant though yeah I mean that's yeah but
that could be a magic string like path
Library path Library handle
um maybe Library name who knows and you
can even be I mean if we wanted to
extend this you know in a world where
say we can read dwarf debug information
it could be all and you get an
association of everything we know we can
determine automatically about that
Library
yeah
yeah that that sounds good
all right so let's go to talk about
types of memory management because I
think right well I was going to show
this example with Rand bytes because I
think it'll make it clear what's sort of
going on here
right so if I if I Define this as a as a
foreign function here so this is this is
where the memory management stuff comes
in though so is very bizarre that return
is is incredibly type theoretic so to
speak this thing yeah so that's another
reason why it's good if it's wrapped up
in some foreign function object that can
have a proper box yeah
um
right but okay but so basically this is
the the place where it gets complicated
because so far you know like with
external like external evaluate has
largely dodged this question because
basically the inputs and outputs of most
interpreted languages are pretty
analogous to what we have in Mathematica
and there aren't really many you know
right but in this situation we need to
allocate a buffer feed that into the
first argument of this it's going to
write a bunch of bytes into it and we
have to read the result out
right so that means that we need to know
how to allocate buffers and we need to
know how to read them back and so on and
we have to be able to memory manage them
because I don't know in this case we
maintain ownership of this buffer but
maybe maybe openssl is going to take
ownership of it in some other case and
so the memory we can't you know we the
memory there has to be a way of manually
managing the memory
um
right I lost something here so it was
like so you were about to demo rent
bytes
yes so Rand bytes if you read the the
documentation generates non-random bytes
and cryptographically secured random
number generator and stores them in buff
right buff is an unsigned Char star it's
just a you know the output of malloc
basically
so the the point is
how do I get a buffer like that from you
know from Mathematica I need to allocate
a buffer and then I need to be able to
feed it in read the result back yep and
and worse just and this is why the
memory management is complicated you
might say well you could automatically
generate it when you call the function
and so on yeah when you're done but you
don't know that because openssl might
take ownership of that buffer so
right
so basically the way to do it is I have
a bunch of these functions and I've
basically
somewhat weirdly used the word buffer to
sort of mean any of these sorts of uh
time and basically any function that
takes or turns a pointer I call it a
buffer because just sort of a some
sequence of bytes so we can try
something like
um
uh list to buffer I have a numeric array
one as well but this is just this work
here so we'll give it some bytes you
know
I don't know or maybe we can say
something more more interesting like uh
two character code you know
um and it will tell it the the type so
in this case it's an unsigned chart
starts it'll say C unsigned char
and or oh uh actually I think it might
be
okay I'm not sure what that that is but
I think unsignature eight should uh
oh no uh okay let me try using the
numerical array one because I don't
remember
how this or maybe I should just look at
the example for list of buffer so I can
do it properly
let me understand something in terms of
the overall design of this packlet
I see a fair amount of complexity here
that is most of the complexity around
this buffer memory management stuff or
is there some other pocket of complexity
as well
um this is I'd say most most the design
complexities just around yeah making
inputs and taking back outputs some of
that's buffers some of that's callbacks
which is another major feature
um
yeah stuff like that though that that is
where most of the complexity is
okay let me just understand all the
complexity though so I mean basically
it's how do you exchange data if it is
being done in a piece of memory that is
managed by the external Library
is that right
it doesn't matter if he's managing it
the point is just you have to deal with
a bunch of C types like C arrays and
stuff like that but what if the thing is
being past destruct for example how do
you specify that
so I have a way of representing the
types for structs there's actually two
ways you can either you know if I say
this instead of it being a c int it was
some struct that contained a field that
was first knit and then a float you can
one way writing as with a list
so this represents a struct of an
Internet float the the the field names
instructs don't exist once it's in a
dynamic Library so I don't represent
them here they're just lists
the sub-value call will just be a list
there exactly that will populate the
struct right lists you know structs get
serialized to you know from lists and
and two lists so yeah okay okay okay so
then then the issue now is how do you
make a c array out of the list for
example that's your list buffer type
thing right that's the list of buffer
type thing in this case I'm going to use
numerical rate of buffer because list
buffer for some reason isn't working but
I mean here just so I'm understanding
and c and is this true in all cabi
languages that the um
uh that you can't pass on the stack an
array you only can pass a pointer to an
array no you you can pass you can pass a
raises arguments but but actually um
they have to be a fixed size that's
known at compile time okay that's what I
thought right you can't pass it
dynamically changing so I mean a length
three list for example you could pass on
the stack right and in fact actually the
way that so lib ffi doesn't natively
support a way to do that but what they
say in the documentation I haven't tried
it is that this is actually equivalent
you know an array of of five ins is
equivalent to a struct with five ends
and so really the thing you do is you
you'd I mean maybe you can do this
internally but it's equivalent to to
this
right
right and it would come back as a list
so it all works out beautifully so your
arrays look like lists and they come out
right
okay I see I see so so then if it were
to return that array or the aura struct
the return value from the function from
the foreign function called as a
sub-value would be a list and it's up to
you to package that in an association
for example
yes but again that's only if it's passed
by value most of the time these things
will pass are raised by by reference so
it'll be something like this
okay
all right so now let's take a look at
this right so we have our Rand bytes
function we have this buffer I'm going
to you know assign it to a variable here
um there are lots of functions for
reading from this buffer so for example
I could say buffer to numeric array
or maybe I could be dangerous to say
buffer to list now I'll give it the
buffer I'll give it the type signature
and I'll give it the length uh
could I just ask Christopher because I
think this is obvious but I want to make
sure so when you do that numerical right
to buffer operation
um
you get to specify the you know the type
of the buffer now I assume that this is
you know this is it's not doing any side
of casting of the numeric array values
you're not casting each value of the
numeric array to an unsigned integer and
if it's bigger than an unsign integer
it's getting truncated or something
you're just you know it's like
so so so numeric arrays right so if it's
just an unsigned to durate it'll just
use the raw buffer this is just using
the compiler's mechanism for for
converting you know interpreting a
numeric array as a numeric array of a
particular type so if it's an unscient
array and I ask for photos on signature
rate I think it'll just copy the buffer
inside the numeric array if it's a
different type it'll attempt to cast it
and it will fail if it doesn't fit
when you just return on a payroll punch
I mean in C you can do all kinds of
stupid points at gymnastics where you
add seven to go you know deeper into the
array and things like this but why are
we not returning there a package thing
that says you know I'm full of unsigned
and traits right so why isn't there type
information the basic reason to two
reasons one reason is because
that's nowhere encoded in lib ffi or in
the way Dynamic libraries work or
anything like that and the idea here is
at least that the the base level of this
should not add any structure that's sort
of not part of the way Dynamic libraries
work
you know so that it can sort of so that
you can do everything and critically
because there are lots of weird cases
where here's a library and oh it says it
returns a number but then you have to
then interpret that number as a function
pointer you know five minutes later and
pass it in somewhere else and if it has
a bunch of type information associated
with it it'll just either have to be
ignored in which case why do you have it
or it will be you know the result of
this is the list to buffer that has to
have type information in it because that
thing there is very raw which is the
nature of the world because it's like
you know right if you get back an
unsigned charge star like you might get
back a void star what the heck can you
do with a voice Star right
right okay and so yeah
okay right but so this this you know now
we're reading uh
you know there we go so so we wrote to a
buffer and we're going right to that
opaque wrote pointer
um yes there's that direction named
populate buffer oh my God I think that I
think that's you does it have any idea
how long that buffer is or does it just
no no okay no
because C doesn't
great you know it's really it's really
outrageous I mean in SMP there were
mechanisms that were very you know
primitive versions of things like this
and you know then we were like this is
not a very good idea because you can
crash your whole session by just making
a small mistake
indeed
okay well I mean the only thing that's
good now is that the cost of starting
processes is much lower and things like
this
so and um there's much more
infrastructure for maintaining you know
that there are many more things which
expect the processors die
I guess maybe yeah
I think
could we include the type information
that numerical rate a buffer results and
I mean for example if you use it in a
context where you're doing an operation
that that
you know in C would just Cast Away the
type incompatibility like let's say you
passed that you know it might return
typed of opaque raw pointer comma
unsigned integer 8 and maybe they're I
mean there could even be a metadata
field for the length
um but then you passed it to something
that has a different type
could could it be you know could we keep
the type information as long as possible
and then have functions that operate on
it that behave in a c like unsafe way
just ignore it if it's incompatible
right so this is sort of the uh right I
think this is a
this is one way it could kind of work so
the main the main problem is just that
either
right as you say either the C functions
just ignore the type information in
which case it's it's a kind of marginal
value its main purpose would just be if
you made it in Mathematica you can then
interpret it in Mathematica but that's
not a very common case you know more
often it's making Mathematica and you
feed it to C and then you get back an
output that's you know won't be
annotated as nicely and then you have to
read that back
um the other thing is these functions
will always have to at least have usages
where you know right that could be an
alternative usage but these functions
will always have to have usages like
this that are fully explicit because
sometimes you do get back a void star
and are told this is a you know an array
of this type of this length and you need
to have some way of of uh of
interpreting it like that
um I mean I guess the question would be
and this probably varies wildly just
from C library to see a library how
disciplined they are about types
I mean if we went the approach of being
somewhat strict where it returns a type
and there's no implicit throwing away of
the type like so for example if you pass
that that numeric array back to uh
buffer to list and you had an
incompatible type it might return an
error instead and you say I mean you
might have to include in your code some
kind of explicit Cast Operation if you
wanted to do that
do we think that so many C libraries
operate in a way where they're just
doing those casts all over the place in
their public API that that would be too
onerous to require that
well here's something that's that's like
very similar to that which I think will
cause similar problems to the design I'm
not sure it's exactly the case you're
talking about but but uh a very common
situation is you have libraries with
opaque objects so for example GEOS you
know like that GEOS intersection
function I had before where I said it
takes two opaque raw pointers those are
Pointers to GEOS geometry objects and
GEOS geometry objects are some giant
struct that's that's opaque right you're
not gonna encode that structure here
um
and so the question is what would you
put you know if you had an array of
those objects you know you could either
do it what happens in the compiler which
is that you declare there's a type I'm
going to call it just geometry and it's
just going to fundamentally be an opaque
pointer but you can still do type
checking to make sure that you know
you're you're not confusing with some
other opaque pointer
or all opaque pointers I think the
fundamental point is you're going to
have to understand a bunch of the stuff
to use this there's no point in
packaging it any further because it's
you know the packaging just isn't that
there's essentially no class of users
who can just use the simple to use
packaging and not have to understand
what's going on underneath
all right it might still be useful to
like like I think I think right the
other goal here was just that this you
know the main thing that's exposed here
is like the minimal you know this is
basically just exposing what lib ffi has
right in in a minimal way you know with
no extra fluff but I think it could make
sense to add some fluff on top of it
um okay let me ask you a different
question you know that ref prop Library
is that I mean is it does it become
trivial to to deal with that Library
through this interface I I don't know
the ref prop library was that the the
like reference materials or something
that's the thing thermodynamic data yeah
yeah
um but it might be
relatively well if it's unfortunate I
don't know if that complicates things
I've never no I still Fortran library
but um I think of how to see like
you know mechanism I mean that to me
it's like in the giant boatloads of
libraries type Theory
you know
the impression is that there are lots of
these libraries out there but it would
be nice to see some more examples
because otherwise it's you know it's
hard to do the design if we don't have
at least you know five or ten examples
right well there's some examples I've
played I mean I've done something you
know I have some short examples like
one-off examples with open SSL I have
some more extended examples using like
sqlite
um
and there was a couple other libraries I
was playing with but uh yeah I mean I've
done real examples with this and with
the compiler stuff and so on I think
it'll be useful to ask Roger and Rob and
people like that about libraries that
they are you know well
yeah actually I because I've spoken to
Rob about this so one of the big and
this is another sort of packaging of the
or maybe a a thing that would be built
on top of this so several people I've
spoken to Rob and pyarcher and things
like that have wanted to link to C plus
plus libraries which is much harder
um and like in particular there's one
that they wanted which was Apache Arrow
um and uh
doesn't C plus plus have a c like
interface no because C plus plus
basically doesn't make libraries like
that or not not not immediately you have
to do compilation in order to you have
to do C plus plus compilation in order
to call a c plus function because
because basically the problem is you
know if I have a C plus plus thing that
has a templated function
you know you have to compile it for
whichever template arguments you want
and that requires compilation
so so the way the CMOS plus libraries
basically work is though they generally
are distributed mostly As header files
and then when you actually want to use
them you just include the header files
and then you know when you compile it'll
compile all those headers and so on so
in the whole world of C plus plus there
aren't Dynamic libraries floating around
well okay two things one C plus plus can
produce Dynamic libraries you have to
basically tell it you have to basically
use this extern C mechanism and
basically uh uh give it a
um you know give it a type signature
that's totally C proved you have to burn
in forget the template you have to burn
in a specific type signature right and
there can't be flat you know you can't
extern see a class like it has to be
functions and so on
um
but right and so basically the way that
this would work is just like with create
form function you basically give a
representation of I have a function this
is its name these are arguments and
return types and so on you'd have to say
I have a c plus class this is its name
these are its template arguments these
are its Constructors these are its
methods
etc etc and then from that it would
create this kind of object that then you
know you could you could call and pass
around and it would automatically
construct them and destruct them and so
on now the main hard part there and of
course when you when you ask for one of
the when you declare it it'll have to do
C plus plus compilation to make a
library that you know that then this the
foreign function interface Library can
link to
um
but uh right I think that system would
actually be very useful and very nice
but it's mostly complicated from a
design perspective because you need to
have some way you know here if I want to
tell you everything you need to know
about a function in order to connect to
it all I need to tell you the argument
types and the return type but there it's
like I need to tell you tons of stuff
about templates and Constructors and
methods and and whatever so it's going
to be an association basically you have
to pass in instead of like if you were
using Farm function
you would then have to instead of just
giving a type signature with an arrow or
something you would be passing an
association of a bunch of stuff like
well I think it's going to be even more
complicated it's going to be some you
know uh
yeah it's going to be some
some
right something like more like this it's
going to be kind of ugly
um because it gets really complicated
and there are a lot of different things
you need to know and it's not simpler to
use some kind of utility library that
just provides a c wrapper around a C
plus plus
function well you mean you mean that we
can use someone else's library that does
this wrapping yeah
so two things one you would still need
to somehow specify what methods you want
what uh sure templates and so on so you
still need to do a lot of this work the
second thing is those libraries as far
as I can tell don't really exist there's
one thing I found called like C3 Peach
and C
that kind of does this
um but otherwise it's unbelievable you
know decades go by and things are still
very primitive anyway never mind yeah I
mean as far as I can tell right like
when I looked at other languages so so
first thing is that lots of languages
have you know basically every
interpreted language I could find has
some version of the ffi built into it
um so so this is very typical to have
something like this but
nothing I could find had a connection to
C plus plus like there's no python
library that I could find in my little
bit of looking that was basically the
you know automatically connected C plus
plus in this style
um
nor was there for Ruby or or Julia or
whatever
um
live stream is asking other examples of
braiding calls into more complicated C
plus plus libraries like dlib or ml pack
what is it braiding I don't know what a
braiding I don't know what that means I
I have to look that up thank you for
asking the question we don't know
um and Nolan's asking about commenting
Cuda is a good library to call out to
but Cuda is a whole different story
isn't it
I mean Cuda link which
is you know a different strategy that we
have to have I mean Cooter is not what
is Cuda is it a library that is it a
c-like library that can be called that
interfaces to gpus or is it something of
a completely different character
I mean I I I don't I'm not I haven't
used it much my uh first of all I think
Cuda Cuda is a language
but it's a language that you probably
passed to some Library we passed like I
think it's called nvcc which is the Cuda
compiler which produces binaries that
you can then use some kind of library to
give those binaries to to your GPU right
okay but so the thing that we are
targeting initially here is see like
interfaced libraries and it will be
really good to get an inventory of those
and to check that those really you know
I mean we know that there are some of
those plenty of those
uh I mean I've already made several of
these so it's like you know geoslink is
one of them you know actually likes
another you know open SSL is another one
that obviously could have been done this
way
that they're they're actually I run into
these quite often
yeah Conor's pointing out that Kuda link
for for Nolan on the live stream we have
a whole Kuda link system
um that
probably could do with some
modernization
that's a whole giant thing for calling
gpus although there's an alternative
path for doing that using our machine
learning framework and we still need to
I don't really understand what the
correct future of all of that is and
really we should be working with GPU
companies on this and we just
everybody's like
too busy and things are not happening
type thing
um but that's uh you know there's that's
a different path but let's let's come
back to this
um right
okay so the basic thing we have to
understand is all this buffering buffer
stuff right well let me finish this
example quickly because then it'll be
clear a little bit more of the
complexity also
okay so we have the function we allocate
the buffer I really I should do this in
a better way so I'll just say
um
random pieces of memory out there
yes
and you're forgetting what the pointers
were and so they're just floating out
there in the on the Heap yes but there's
a solution down just a moment okay so
here's a buffer of 10 unfined integer
you know uh inside the traits if I do
buffer to list of of that and you see
it's just a you know on uninitialized
memory right there might be something in
it or it might be zeros or God only
knows so we're essentially calling
malloc
and this is essentially doing Peak
like you know old-fashioned in what was
it basic yes the function Peak that just
looks at Raw memory
okay well yeah he can also
what's that Todd knows what I'm talking
about he can poke sure
right they look at Raw memory
the right well this is peaking and
poking and there's a bunch of raw memory
in it okay so so if you want to use this
though then you'd say you know call on
function and we'll give it the Rand
bytes we'll give it the buffer and we'll
give it the length of the buffer as it
as it asks for if we run that it returns
an error code I think one means it
worked but I don't know but now if we
type buffer to list we'll see now it's
been populated with a bunch of probably
random bytes and if I run it again you
can get new ones
so in order to make this a bit safer
though because you know right now we're
writing the same buffer a bunch of times
but but we need to free the stopper so
so the first thing is there's a function
delete buffer
uh that freeze a buffer don't run this
again because it'll crash your kernel
right I've already read it now what
happens if I then say buffer the list on
that buffer it'll now be it'll still be
able to do that
it depends right right you will now be
reading from memory that you're yeah
right so what happens does it work I
think there's a there's a non-zero
probability of crashing the kernels why
because of virtual memory mapping
I I think because I you know os's have
all kinds of ways to try and make sure
you don't read memory you're not
supposed to and uh
depending on random chance I think this
might crash because I'm not going to try
it
um
the way you the way you should do this
better is when you create the buffer
right because we know that the stuff
we're you know we're always going to
maintain ownership of it there's a
function called create managed
expression
um and basically you give it you give it
I mean this this at some level is not
specific to buffers that you can do for
anything so whether you have F comma
Echo right we now have this object and
if I say get
you know get managed expression of that
it'll return you know it'll return the
app but when this magic object when its
reference count goes to zero it'll call
Echo event
it's like if I do um you know
right you see a call that going back
look at this thing got that's cool
um so basically right so if I do it like
this we're gonna have this buffer object
which is this opaque raw pointer
but it's going to be wrapped up in this
magic thing that should have a better
box but which we'll call the lead object
on this whenever it's reference count
goes to zero
so now I can call this and I can you
know get the buff the things out I don't
have to call to make buffer on it and it
will automatically be freed whenever it
goes out of scope if somebody does a one
argument form of create managed
expression which has a delete so the
appropriate delete as a second argument
oh I should have said um delete uh
buffer well
um maybe yeah I mean the only I guess it
probably could the only problem is just
that it isn't uh
well
right it's not always clear what the the
the delete is so for example if you have
no pay crop pointer yeah um maybe it's
pointing to a GEOS geometry object yeah
who knows in which case you need to call
the free GEOS geometry function fine I
retract my comment I think it's not I
think it's hopeless
um
right so so this is the the basic this
is a very typical flow is you create the
function and then the actual body you
know and we could patch this as a you
know
Jen bites
right
um you know
right this is this is a very typical way
you would do something like this
and now
right and that will clean up after
itself
right
cool
also just as a random note just to sort
of uh show off so if I do it as a
numeric way that works too and now if I
try
you know I know something like that
um
that's far says
oh I shouldn't uh
but yeah it's it's it's like
consistently like an order of magnitude
or something faster than that random
integer
nice
that's just open SSL is fast yeah um
is this is this a criticism of random
integer and that maybe we could make it
faster or is this just random integer by
default perhaps uses a more secure
mechanism than this Rand bytes function
that's a separate topic
I mean I think I think right random
venture has all kinds of fancy things it
does but I have to imagine I mean random
integers does not claimed to be
cryptographically secure and uh random
bites does so I wouldn't say that uh to
Graphics security and statistical you
know Randomness aren't necessarily that
related and blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah complicated
story
um we're about to run out of time here
and we clearly have much more to go
through I think we should
schedule another one of these
um
uh
I mean mainly we're talking about
the packaging of this memory management
stuff
and
I mean you know
scroll back up is a list of functions
all right down yeah
right I have a guide page
for the magic of documentation
well you probably could isn't it
yeah I I probably have a
um an actual page don't you have a click
on your right hand top right hand thing
where you have your custom guide Pages
which you didn't use and nor do I yet
oh not right hand side of your
documentation
here yeah ah well I don't really want to
make a new one
yeah that's kind of stupid isn't it we
should make that okay that's a thing for
for Aubry let's we should make sure that
that has the thing to say add existing
guide page to that thing in the top
right hand corner I don't think we
considered this case a packlet once
about it
thanks well I'll just we'll look at the
uh this one for now then
um
right sorry so this is this is basically
the the functions
we've got
right the basics talk about creating and
calling functions a whole bunch of stuff
for for dealing with basically pointers
offers memory
um
then the managed expression thing which
I which I showed and then callbacks
which are a whole other I'll maybe show
a very short example of callbacks so
here
this documentation example is not very
good but but right here we have a uh a
library that has a function in it and
the function expects a function pointer
yep
um and it's a function pointer that
takes along and returned along and what
it's going to do is going to make an
array and it's going to you know call
this function on a bunch of numbers and
it's going to populate some array and
return it
so okay so if we make that library and
we load it
we can then you know create a link to
that library and we say that it takes an
opaque pointer because it function
pointers are just pointers
then there's this function create
callback which I'll first just show on
its own and basically you just give it
any expression here and uh you know and
a type signature and it creates this
callback object now for for reasons you
know right the reason I can explain a
moment you need to have uh manual memory
management reviews because you don't
know when it basically has to do
allocation when you say create callback
and you don't know if the library or
calling is taking ownership of this
callback it needs to not be read so
there needs to be manual memory
management that's but okay so if I if I
have this callback
um right here I've memory managed it but
whatever then we can feed that to this
this function you know and you see it's
going and and it's evaluating this thing
in the kernel it's actually going it's
calling the stuff that's really cool you
know in the kernel so you can do I have
lots of examples doing things like sew
and reap and all that stuff works
um so wait a minute so basically the
point is this is a cheap way to get an
external C program to call
I mean this is the analog let me just
understand I mean like for example the
python client library is a way to call
in to
although that's working through a
completely different connectivity
mechanism this is a way that you could
in principle
so this isn't an alternative mechanism
for anything
this is just that sometimes you know
like Suppose there was some C library
you saw and it had a function called map
right this isn't very common you see
that but suppose you saw a function
called map in the C library to which you
expect to function as an argument right
and this is what you feed it as a
function pointer and that function
pointer then becomes a callback so the
function pointer it's the analog of an
external function our external function
it is the C analog of an external
function so to speak right another great
thing about is it it lets see call the
kernel yes it does that right
which is and it is kind of an inverse
because basically what what's happening
is that when whenever this thing gets
called it has to take a c long convert
it to an expression evaluate it and then
convert the result of that back to a c
long
right
that's very cool
all right listen we need to schedule a
different time to continue with this
um this really nice really nice
um I don't think else we need to cover
right the second
I don't think so I think I've probably
been the thing is I'll try and make some
of these package this up in a few ways
we talked about and maybe have a uh you
know kind of a list of things to talk
about next time right let's schedule
this soon I mean we can we're ready to
you know we could have gone on longer
here and but this is uh
it's very cool even if even if it's sort
of horrifying that it's interesting that
the world of sort of this level of
engineering has actually
at some level the the things one needs
to do Peaks and pokes and so on
I mean Peak and poke must be 50 years
old more than that
I don't know anyway it's interesting all
right I should run great see you see you
later thanks to folks on live stream as
well
all right